this one comes from tupac cabra who has
a twitter account that's
oh link in the description does the
catholic church have their own term
slash practice slash training for remote
viewing and if so does it predate the us
governments and how put offs programmed
that's a good question they actually do
and if you it's not called remote
viewing um but it's called discernment
and so um
we've talked about people in the
invisible college a lot of them being
catholics i don't know if all of them
are but
most of them are
and so um one of those people is jacques
jacques vale
and when i first met him and throughout
my
um collegial friendship with him
um
he's
said to use your discernment and this is
something that must be developed okay
and so that caused me um to recognize
the term as being from the catholic
tradition because that's you know
obviously but something that we we use a
lot but we don't know what it means and
what you know what's the context of this
and catholic history so you go back and
you look at where this develops and
basically it's this recognition that
humans have the ability of to see things
that you can't you know
humans in general some humans have it
more than other humans to be able to see
or have information about
people or events
um that
you couldn't like get in a normal way
through the five senses or something
like that and that's called discernment
and
so yeah so i think that cultivating a
spiritual practice
is what
helps one
discern um the remote viewing community
gave specific instructions for how to
cultivate
uh the prac you know the ability of
remote viewing um in my opinion though
they left out
some of that the ways in which you can
not go crazy and do it at the same time
because i think there's a point where
you're going to get a lot of information
that you don't quite understand don't
know how to deal with and you know i
think that spiritual traditions have
things in place to help people with that
um so
you know the catholic church has its own
you know internal group of you know if
these things start to happen to you
think this way in buddhism you have the
same thing if you start to see these
things or if you start to have you know
uh recognition of events that are going
to happen um ignore them or something
like that you see what i'm saying so
to utilize these talents for gain
material gain
or
for selfish reasons um
i think that this is this is something
that one in my personal opinion this is
not me speaking as a professor but in my
personal opinion i wouldn't really do
that
um
but that's how remote viewing in these
communities has been used not
necessarily for personal gain
but um
you know for
obviously
some corporations use it to assess what
other corporations are doing um
obviously if national security if this
was something that national security
would want to obviously russians have
been doing remote viewing you know uh
the americans have been doing it as well
um so yeah so
yeah so i think that you see this within
different religious traditions but the
contexts are different
and you know the
the
you know the desires for the
consequences are different as well
when i was speaking to this guy named
thomas campbell not on ufos in fact i
don't think he has an opinion on them as
far as i can tell but he has a theory
called my big toe quote unquote
he said that people have the ability to
do remote viewing and i think you called
it by
location or the
catholics right which is some form of
astral projection and he said but it can
only be used for non-selfish purposes
and that if you wanted to win the
lottery or
prove it to someone else which is a
strange
way of phrasing it because then it
sounds like it's unfalsifiable if what
you're doing is
trying to bolster your ego in some sense
then it doesn't work so you're saying
that actually no other cases occur where
you're aware of or you believe to be the
case that some corporations have used it
for profit and
perhaps some nefarious purpose on parts
of some government
or no you're not saying that well no not
necessarily nefarious if it's for
national security i mean they're doing
it in order to gain you know information
to protect americans or
russians to protect russians i mean you
know that's their job so
they saw that this actually works so
they
tried to utilize it um ed may
who i met at the rice conference uh the
archives of the impossible conference
had a great presentation on remote
viewing
and um
he would be the person to talk to but
yeah within the catholic church there is
something like that but it's it's
completely
devoid of this this use right and
also
i've seen kind of these kinds of
practices in buddhism as well but again
totally devoid of this type of
let's do
you know this let's do this for
to find out what our enemies think or
let's do this to find out what our
competitors think so we could get the
upper hand